[Musique]
c'est brillant
tous les cadres de notre boîte sont
bardés de diplômes
la seule chose qui peut arrêter c'est
toi
[Musique]
vous avez déjà fait un point sur votre
vie en vous demandant comment vous en
étiez arrivé là si vous choix avait été
différent sauriez-vous plus heureux
arthur a obtenu un master radio auquel
il a le meilleur profil pour ce poste
lors monsieur c'est moi
je voudrais vivre dans un monde où les
débrouillards sont aussi valorisé que
les intellos je les emmerde à qui tous
ces super diplômés avec leur jolie
maison leurs gosses qui ont des noms de
fruits et leur ascension du kilimandjaro
car si un coup de fil pour un entretien
d'embauché oh merde chez franklin clark
votre cv m'intéresse business school de
word comment quand on regarde son
incroyable page facebook la page
facebook
obama j'étais fabriquer une nouvelle
identité
tu voulais être au top niveau alors j'ai
fait de toi une cendrillon en mode cloud
c'est vrai que tout ça vient d'un
mensonge m'épater crochet jack ma belle
quitter la championne à l'école c'est
quoi une championne toujours bien de thé
une championne à lyon ce matin
ça va être difficile d'avoir un job à
votre âge c'est ce qu'on verra un
habillage
[Musique]
ça va tu mets tout ce que tu veux sauf
ça on dirait madame doubtfire war c'est
mon bureau et au filet un appartement et
des cartes de crédit au pack suprême
stage les gardes tu touche pas les
jambes arquées souter tu vas leur avouer
la vérité pas vrai je peux y arriver
c'est pas maya bargas ce sont mes amis
de norton wharton en a fait beaucoup
d'humanitaires enfin on a sauvé des
baleines c'est
je ne confonds pas ta vie sur facebook
avec qui tu es vraiment je vous admire
beaucoup dans quelques années je
voudrais tellement vous ressemble
[Musique]
tu as toujours été au top tu étais là
solaire en tout cas nous aimerions nous
implanter en chine est la seule employée
qui part monde arabe
moi j'ai une idée note veto parle
couramment mandarin
nous serons ravis de vous faire une
visite guidée et ont donc eu la corse
aussi et d'abord retiré des trafics au
corps malade
[Musique]